it's been a whole console generation
since we last saw shepard
tally garrus and the rest of the
normandy crew mass effect legendary
edition remasters bioware space opera
rpg trilogy for the new generation of
consoles
enhancing the visuals implementing
quality of life improvements and making
welcome adjustments to certain content
for all three games
in those adjustments legendary edition
occasionally draws unwanted attention to
parts of the trilogy that haven't aged
gracefully
but as a whole this remaster is a good
way to see what all the fuss is about if
you missed out on the first three mass
effect games
the first time around or just looking
for a reason to dive into them again
the core of mass effect is its choice
and consequence driven narrative
as commander shepard the first human to
be given the role of a spectre in the
inner species milky way government you
were put into many situations where you
have the final say
on how things go down your choices in
the first game can
influence how characters perceive you or
how events transpire
in the second which then can domino
effect into the third
it's up to you to decide whether you
wish to be a paragon of virtue
or results oriented renegade you talk
too much
see the human cannot hit a simple tart
while this consequence driven system
seems to allow a great deal of agency in
how you resolve certain conflicts
it's rigid in its design basing the
entirety of shepard's morality on a
binary system of paragon and renegade
choices
its simplicity does make the system
fairly approachable reducing the
complexity of every decision to a
morally good
and morally bad choice additionally from
an accessibility standpoint
splitting shepard's choices into a rigid
binary helps with better understanding
the underlying nuance to certain
dialogue
choices but in sticking to this rigid
binary the mass effect trilogy strips
the tension from certain situations
mass effect 2 possesses one of the most
egregious examples where one of the
later missions finishes with asking you
whether you want to brainwash an entire
group of people to think the same way
that you do
or simply kill them all up to that point
your squadmates provide pros and cons
for committing to either option
but the game then regulates the former
as the paragon choice
and the latter as renegade this
undermines the implied tension of the
choice this should be an impossibly
difficult decision to make when it comes
down to it do you think that it is
better to deal with those who disagree
with you via indoctrination
or genocide but the trilogy's binary
choice system removes that nuance
telling the player that
in this instance at least remaking
someone without their knowledge is
morally better
than killing them the game reduces all
of its conflicts to paragon vs renegade
this can make the mass effect trilogy
feel unrewarding at times at certain
points across
all three games special paragon and
renegade dialogue options will pop
up that allow you to resolve the
situation and achieve an ideal outcome
but you can only pick these
choices if you have enough paragon or
renegade points
which are earned by picking paragon or
renegade dialogue options
so to get the best outcomes for certain
situations you need to make a lot of
paragon or renegade choices
encouraging you to lean one way or the
other it's not very satisfying to see
how your choices play out across three
games
if you're being funneled down to one of
two predetermined paths
but the mass effect trilogy's strength
has always existed in the story around
those choices not the choices themselves
and legendary edition holds true to that
the trilogy's most memorable moments
have been preserved
mass effect 2's loyalty missions are
still some of the best storytelling that
bioware has ever done
and although mass effect 1 still doesn't
deliver a compelling reason to really
romance
anyone its two follow-ups better utilize
the romance feature
adding replayability as you explore all
possible relationships
and on top of that legendary edition's
content adjustments and visual
enhancements
do add new memorable moments for
returning fans to enjoy
so even if you've replayed the trilogy a
half dozen times there are still new
ways to appreciate the games in this
remaster i love what legendary edition
does for eden prime mass effect 1's
opening level for example
in the original game the sky was
blanketed in murky red clouds with
lightning flashing it looked like the
end of the world had already occurred
and you were coming in on the tail end
of an invasion not
during it in the remaster mass effect 1
now opens on a sunny day
which i find to be far more eerie this
change shifts mass effect 1 to better
align with the openings of mass effect 2
and mass effect 3 both of which also
begin with an unforeseen
unknowable force interrupting business
as usual
mirroring the greater framework of how
these games are composed of simple
seemingly everyday decisions being
interrupted by brutal consequence
gonna reach ashley williams of the 212.
you the one in charge here sir
most of the scenes and character models
in legendary edition are enhanced with
more detailed graphics
and improved lighting this has done
wonders for many of the alien characters
especially your squad mates
some of the human characters however
aren't as lucky especially for folks who
are darker skinned
in locations where there are a lot of
reflective surfaces the remaster as mass
effect 1 brightens up their faces in a
way that creates blotches of
white on their skin almost like the
characters were in the midst of applying
shiny paint to their faces
when shepherd came along it's never a
great look though it occurs far less in
legendary editions mass effect 2
and even less so in mass effect 3. and
to that end not all of legendary
edition's enhancements are good the
increased lighting in some scenes
reveals the lack of detail
in certain environments additionally the
models for some characters lose a bit of
their original charm in this remaster
in legendary edition kelly chambers
features are muted for example subduing
the redhead with bright green eyes into
a brunette with brownish green eyes
her new design isn't as unique and
doesn't stand out as easily as it did
before
but these are all minor complaints for
the most part the mass effect trilogy's
original vision has been preserved in
this remaster
the exceptions largely exist in
legendary edition's mass effect 1.
the most noteworthy is mass effect 1's
combat which has been improved to be
less temperamental than the original
release
shepard snaps the cover more seamlessly
in the remaster for instance
there are a couple of other small
adjustments too like improved aim assist
so it's easier to strafe targets and a
dedicated melee button so you can decide
whether to shoot
or punch out an enemy rushing your
position the overall effect is that it
no longer feels like you're fighting the
enemy
and the controls in the midst of a
firefight dying in legendary editions
mass effect 1
is a far less frustrating affair as a
result when it happens it's more likely
due to mistake on your part as opposed
to the mechanics or controls not playing
nice
granted there are still issues certain
biotic and tech abilities can uselessly
glide into a wall if your target
sidesteps out of your line of sight
as powers don't curve around cover like
their mass effect 2 and mass effect 3
counterparts
it doesn't happen all the time but it
happens enough times to be noticeable
and annoying
especially in the enclosed spaces found
in all the bases you'll uncover across
mass effect 1's
many optional side missions it's notably
still a bit janky
lacking the polished improvements that
made mass effect 3's combat good enough
to warrant the addition of a multiplayer
horde mode
the mako and legendary editions mass
effect 1 is also a bit janky lacking the
vehicular control seen in mass effect
2's hammerhead
but it thankfully at least handles
better than it did in the original game
the explorable planets and legendary
editions mass effect 1 are still bare of
sights to see
and a bit of a slog in the repetitive
collectibles and missions but at least
it's now a bit easier to drive on them
legendary edition makes a few changes to
the trilogy's content too like adjusting
the picture you get of tally's face in
mass effect 3s it doesn't look like a
poorly photoshopped stock photo
so even though legendary edition isn't a
full-blown remake
it goes beyond a traditional remaster
adjusting the very content of the game
so that it's an improved experience
but as i mentioned in the intro the one
major downside to these improvements is
that it further highlights the original
drawbacks of the mass effect trilogy
that were not changed for the remaster
like the game's poor depiction of mental
disabilities
and autism there are small examples like
mass effect 1's dr warren noting that
genius and madness are two sides of the
same coin
and larger examples too such as mass
effect 2's david archer
a man who's autistic being used as a
prop the misunderstood quote
monster and the overlord dlc which is a
story that largely focuses on the dr
frankenstein like abuser
dr gavin archer instead of the victim
neither of these instances have been
changed in legendary edition they were
problematic when these games first
released and remain so now
and there are other examples of
problematic content across the trilogy
pieces of bioware's original games that
have
not aged gracefully years later as a
result legendary edition can feel
strange to play through during certain
moments
it feels like the remaster only takes a
half step toward
improvement in certain aspects legendary
edition also launches with pretty much
all of the trilogy's dlc
but these expansions are implemented in
a way that make them more difficult to
enjoy for newcomers
for example mass effect 2's the lair of
the shadow broker is unlocked as soon as
you finish act 1 of the game
when you're allowed to travel to ilium
for the first time so you know you have
information for liara before you know
it's even possible to meet
up with her you have information to help
her track down the shadow broker prior
to completing errands for her
and learning that she's hit a dead end
in her search for the shadow broker
returning players will know to hold off
and let the story play out in a way that
makes sense
but newcomers can easily just stumble
into that dlc without knowing they
should do other stuff first
legendary edition fails to seamlessly
integrate all of its expansions into the
trilogy's overall story which can lead
to an annoyingly
inconsistent narrative the remaining
changes in legendary edition are small
but still worth shouting out first off
i'm disappointed that the trilogy does
not have a truly
unified character creator as shepherd's
morality in mass effect 2 and mass
effect 3 plays a hand in whether they
have scars
the option to add scars is only in mass
effect 1's character creator
it's a bit weird to see my shepherd
somehow lose her badass scars
in between the events of mass effect 1
and mass effect 2.
also i can understand why but i'm still
sad that mass effect 3's multiplayer
didn't make the cut
mass effect 3's combat is still
amazingly solid nearly 10 years later
on the more positive side legendary
edition's improved load times are
wonderful removing much of the
frustrating waiting and getting lost on
the citadel
or dying to the same enemy over and over
additionally
it's awesome to finally see a default
female shepherd across all three games
all in all mass effect legendary edition
isn't this huge transformation for the
original trilogy
the remastered mass effect 1 is a more
enjoyable experience than playing the
original game today
it makes for a far more palatable entry
point to the series and mass effect 2
and mass effect 3 look far better than
they did before with minor but welcome
changes to specific pieces of content
but otherwise this remaster delivers the
same experience the original trilogy did
in some respects that's not a wholly
good thing time is reinforced and made
clear
certain underlying issues of the trilogy
but there's a reason the mass effect
trilogy is beloved by so many
its strength resides in the wonderful
journey that it sends you on
one that's preserved in this remaster
you